les lecteurs étaient nombreux vendredi
matin à l'ouverture des portes du 10e
salon du livre des premières nations il
ya vraiment un intérêt de plus en plus
prononcée de plus en plus manifeste la
part du grand public québécois au cours
de la dernière décennie l'écriture
autochtone a grandement évolué le
beaucoup plus d'auteurs pratiquants
c'est à dire pas juste des gens qui
publie un livre et puis qui passe à
autre chose mais vraiment des auteurs
qui ont des carrières et surtout une
diversification notable de des styles
des gens en iran du los sonaires point
de vue ce il ya cinq six ans on peut
avoir autant des trucs
disons policiers ou dans lequel tu
devrais dire que des trucs plus
ténébreux que des trucs très très joyeux
donc au niveau des genres des styles une
explosion il y en a pour tous les goûts
je pense que c'est ce qui fait aussi
qu'un intérêt grandissant parce que le
grand public peut plus trouver son
compte peu importe ses intérêts michel
jean joséphine bacon natasha khan ap
fontaine et d'autres grands noms de la
littérature des premières nations sont
présents ce week end la programmation du
salon du livre est bien plus qu'une
succession de séances de dédicaces pour
moi c'est véritablement plus un festival
c'est à dire que si on trouve
différentes façon d'incarner la
littérature et c'est ça qui est
important pour moi on est des
facilitateurs moi c'est comme ça que je
vois le salon table ronde entretien
expositions et spectacles
les activités se multiplient sous
différentes formes toujours autour de la
littérature
le salon du livre des premières nations
se poursuit jusqu'à dimanche ici tanya
beaumont radio canada québec